-My next guest
is a talented actress
who you can see
on the hit show "Riverdale"
every Wednesday night
at 8:00 p.m., on the CW.
Here is Camila Mendes.
Oh!
Hey! It's so great to see you.
-Hi!
-Thank you
so much for doing this.
-So good to see you, yeah.
-Are you in Vancouver?
-I'm in Vancouver.
-Doing "Riverdale."
-I'm doing "Riverdale."
I just got out of quarantine
like two weeks ago.
-What did the cast get up to
when you were
in quarantine for two weeks?
-In quarantine?
-Yeah.
-For the second quarantine,
like, I kind of hate it
when people make me feel really
[bleep] about not seeing movies.
Like, if I haven't seen, like,
a really classic movie,
and people are like,
"You've never seen that?"
And they make you feel terrible.
-I know!
-I hate that.
I feel like it's --
-"Hey, it's fine
if you haven't seen it.
We're different people,
and I have time to grow,
and I could watch it tomorrow."
-Yeah, there's like 500,000
movies in existence,
but I was like, "I've never
seen 'Lord of the Rings.'"
I think I saw it
when I was like 5 years old
with my cousin or something.
-Yeah.
-Don't remember it,
and every time people
talk about it,
I'm like, "Oh, I don't know,"
and they're like, "What?!"
and they freak out.
So we did it in quarantine.
And then, we decided to watch
the best cinematic trilogy
of all time.
-Ooh, let me think.
What is it?
"Godfather."
-"High School Musical."
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah, that's right.
I forgot.
It is "High School Musical."
-It is "High School Musical."
-Is there three of them?
-There's three of them.
And the third one, Jimmy --
the third one
you have to see it.
They went all-out
for the third one.
-How'd I miss the third one?
-They made it
a full cinematic experience.
It went to theaters, so it
wasn't just on Disney Channel.
-I do remember this!
-It was in theaters.
'Cause it was, like, their big
graduation, you know?
Like, saying goodbye
to the franchise
and all the characters.
And the music was next level.
-Yeah, not only
did I remember it,
I think I did see it
in the theaters, by the way.
-Did you?
-Yeah, I actually did go
to the theater to see it
because I was actually
really psyched out.
Like, me and some of the writers
were like all into it.
In fact,
I totally remember this.
-We were all watching it, like,
"Is this what it's gonna be like
when 'Riverdale's' over?"
Like, I hope they do
the same thing, like, we all,
like, jump into the air.
-[ Laughing ]
Freeze frame.
-[ Laughs ]
-But you're kind of --
You're kind of doing it
with this season
a little bit, though.
-Yeah, we just
had our graduation episode
last night, actually.
-Yeah, but -- And now we get
to see the next episode,
what happens
to you guys in the future.
-We fast-forward like
seven years, or we time-jump.
And now our characters
are like in their mid 20s,
and they all have, like,
their own separate lives.
And then, Archie calls them
and kind of, like, summons them
back to Riverdale
for a mysterious reason.
-You guys,
I heard that you play a game
that's kind of interesting
to me.
-This game is actually so fun to
play, and I highly recommend it.
Like, when we're sitting
in our tent, really bored,
and it's, like, big days when,
like, the whole cast is there,
we'll play a game called
"What Are the Odds?"
And, basically, you kind of,
like, pick a task.
Like, I'd say,
"Jimmy, what are the odds
you eat an entire
watermelon right now?"
And then you have to pick
a number between 1 and 30.
Like, what would you say
are your odds?
-An entire watermelon?
30.
-An entire. 30?
-Yeah.
-And then we would count down.
Like, someone would go,
"3, 2, 1,"
and then we'd both
have to say a number,
and if we say the same number,
you have to eat
that whole watermelon."
-I get it.
This is a really fun game.
But it sounds dangerous
a little bit.
-It is a little dangerous,
because, like,
there's some things I wouldn't
share here that we've done,
that we made each other do.
-Yep.
-I think it's not --
-Yeah.
Did anyone have to eat
an entire watermelon?
-Oh, yeah, Drew Ray Tanner had
to eat an entire watermelon.
-Oh, really?
[ Laughing ]
He looked sick to his stomach
by the end of it.
We had Casey --
Casey lost one
where he had to sit
on the floor the whole day.
Like, he wasn't allowed
to sit in a chair.
[ Both laugh ]
It's just, like,
stupid things like that.
It's not even, like,
that challenging sometimes.
And then, one of them,
I think --
I don't remember if he
ever ended up posting it,
but we had Charles, we said,
"What are the odds
you would post on your Instagram
that your lips are fake?"
Like, make a video confessing
that you have fake lips.
And I think he did it
and then deleted it,
'cause we were like, "Oh, wait.
People might actually
believe you."
I don't remember.
-Camila, I always love
having you on the show,
but I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Camila Mendes in next
week's episode of "Riverdale."
Take a look at this.
-It's 2021, Chad.
Haven't you heard?
Women can have it all now.
-I just...
I don't want you
to be unduly stressed.
-I'm not stressed.
Actually, I miss being on
the trading floor with you.
I miss all that adrenaline.
The highs of a filthy huge sale,
talking smack with the guys.
[ Chuckles ]
They called me
the She-Wolf of Wall Street.
Camila Mendes.
"Riverdale" airs
Wednesday nights
at 8:00 p.m., on the CW.